الى القرم من جديد تتجه اعين السياسيين
والعسكريين في حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
يزيد الاوكرانيون من كثافه هجماتهم فوق
شبه الجزيره اقصى جنوبي البلاد تلك جزيره
تسيطر عليها روسيا منذ عام 2014 وتؤكد
انها اراضي روسيه خالصه في مقابل رفض
اوكراني وتاكيد انها لن تصبح روسيه
بالتقدم في الساعات الماضيه تعلن وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه احباط هجومين اوكرانيين
كانا يستهدفان منشات داخل روسيا لمسيرتين
جرى اسقاطهما في المجال الجوي فوق مياه
البحر الاسود على الارض تقول كييف انها
تواصل عملياتها الهجوميه باتجاه مدينه
تعتبر بوابه الى شبه جزيره القبر تقع من
تبول على خط سكه حديد يربط روسيا بالقرم
والاراضي الاخرى التي تسيطر عليها جنوبيه
اوكرانيا تمت اهداف كثيره لاوكرانيا في
القرن مو ومطارات مدنيه وعسكريه وقواعد
جويه وبحريه ومنشات حيويه للوجود الروسي
في شبه الجزيره الاهم في هذا كله ميناء
سيفاستوبول مقر اسطول البحر الاسود الروسي
يدي روسيا طولا نحو المياه الدافئه يوازيه
في الاهميه جسر القرن او كريتش الذي يربط
شبه الجزيره بالاراضي الروسيه ويعتبر خط
الامداد للقوات الروسيه في المنطقه
الجنوبيه بالكامل اكتوبر الماضي هاجمت
المخابرات الاوكرانيه جسر للمره الاولى
منذ اندلاع الحرب فردت موسكو بقصف كييف
بعد امتناع عن ذلك لاشهر بعد بدء الحرب
اليوم يؤكد المستشار في الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه ان الامر تغير
اليوم لدينا الامكانيات لتدمير كل شيء
روسي في شبه جزيره القرم اذكر العمل ماضي
كان هناك اعتراض على هذا ولكن الان اذا
اخذنا في الاعتبار عدد الدول التي تدعمنا
في هذا الاطار فاننا نستطيع تدمير كل شيء
روسي في الاراضي المحتله
يعتبر نائب رئيس مجلس الامن القومي الروسي
ان هذا الضوء الغربي سيكون سببا لشن حرب
اوسع وسيمنح موسكو اطارا قانونيا للتحرك
ضد الجميع تتهم موسكو الغرب بتسهيل
العمليات الاوكرانيه ضد الاهداف الروسيه
في القرد فوق البحر الاسود تلاحق مقاتله
سوخوي 30 الروسيه مسيره ريبر الامريكيه
وتمنعها من دخول الاجواء الروسيه فوق
القرد قبل اشهر معدوده تعلن موسكو اسقاط
مسيره امريكيه في الاجواء ذاتها ووفق
الاتهامات الروسيه فان المسيره الامريكيه
تزود الاوكرانيين بالمعلومات اللازمه
لاستهداف المواقع
في البحر تعلن كييف للمره الاولى تشكيله
وحده منفصله للمسيرات البحريه يؤكد رئيس
جهاز امن الدوله الاوكرانيه ان هدف هذه
الوحده هو استهداف جسر القرم والقطع
البحريه الروسيه في البحر الاسود وبين كون
القرم عمق الروسيا ام ارضا اوكرانيه محتله
تراوح المواقف الاوكرانيه يشير الرئيسكي
لان استهداف العمق الروسي سيجعل
الاوكرانيين يواجهون مصيرهم وحدهم لكن
وزير خارجيته يوضح اليوم ان الاوكرانيين
جاهزون للمضي قدما في استهداف العمق
الروسي وفي مقدمته القرم هكذا تتحول القرم
الى عنوان مهم في حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
مع ضوء اخضر غربي تتحدث عنه كييف وتحذير
روسي من قلب المعادله